- Nabi Alexandre Chartier à
Montréal merci beaucoup.
- Merci.
Et avec nous pour parler de
l'importerté Montréal,
Rita Baga, drag queen.
- Merci de me recevoir.
- Vous êtes une des drag queen
les plus connues du Canada.
Et le festival de la Fierté a
été important dans
carrière. Qu'est-ce que le
festival représente pour vous?
- J'ai évolué comme
professionnel à la fierté
Montréal pendant cette année
comme directeur de la
programmation et maintenant je
suis de côté, sur la scène.
C'est une façon de briller et de
rester en contact avec ses
festivals.
- Demain, vous avez votre
spectacle qui s'ape qui s'ape qs
superstars. Parlez-nous-en.
- C'est - C'est - C'est - C'estn
du genre. N'a pas eu depuis les
dernières années pour desraisont
maintenant.
On est très excité et c'est un
rassemblement de dragues queen
et king qui du succès et ce
serait des compétitions. ou
queen de l'univers et on les
rassemble Hussen demain à 20
heures.
- Vous a des milliers
de personnes. Il y a 23 000
personnes qui s'éts qui s'éts qs
à votre spectacle vous pouvez,
accueillaccueillaccueillaccueile
mais pas tant que ça.
- La capacité actuelle c'est 30
000 mais jamais on avait pensé
rassembler 23 000 personnes
comme ce fut le cas de la
dernière édition.
Tout est possible pour demain.
- Vous parlez d'une fête et ça
rassemble plusieurs personnes.
Est-ce qMontréal eMontréal eMont
purement festive où il y a
encore un rôle de
sensibilisation, qui est
important pour le festival?
- Le festival est un événement
fédérateur qui a plusieurs
pamphlets, plusieurs
destinations évocations.
Il y a la sphère lui dit que je
représente avec les spectacles
de mémés événements phares reste
le défilé la journée communauté
le but est de mettre la lumière
sur des communautés plus
marginalisées.
Et le combat de la
sexuelle et de genre et
d'actualité dans 70 pays dans le
monde où on ne peut pas être qui
on est on se dit queer.
Mon à ce privilège au Québec à
Montréal. Les gens se demandentn
va le faire tant et aussilongtec
il n'y a pas d'équité et
d'égalité que chaque personne
soit pas libre dans son pays.
V personnes dans le mond
- vous parlez de 110 personnes
dans le monde vous.
Et on parlait de criminalité
encore à Montréal et les crime
haineux ture raciale
et de nature sexuelle.
ue vous le sentez ce
défi qui existe au Canada, cette
discrimination qui est encore
Canada?- La pandémie a exacerbés
comportements sociaux plus
néfastes et malheureusement
discrimination va des personnes
de diversité cette du genre se
sont amplifiées. Je pense à mes
amis qui se sont battus pour...
ce que sont les comportementsars
alors qu'on ne choisit pas
d'être dans la diversité
sexuelle et de gens comme on ne
choisit pas d'aimer le chocolat
puisque LaValley. Il y a unevern
vit dans le respect.
Et on ne peut que dans un mo
meilleur.
- Est-ce que vous inquiétez de
cette tendance Hausser crime
haineux sont à la hausse ou vous
pensez que peut-être davantage
il y a des personnes qui se
rapprochent et on va dans la
bonne direction. C'est difficile
e que vous
ressentez? Est-ce que ça va dans
la bonne direction?
- Je ne sais pas s'il en a plus
aussi on aura pas de plus au cas
où des événements mais chosecers
événements isolés. Il n'y a pas
des crime haineux qui soit d
crimes de LGBTQ possible, avec
la représentation de la sphère
médiatique il y a un dialogue et
les gens comprennent plus la
réalité de nos communautés. On
s'en va vers la bonne direction
mais il  à
faire.
- Je vais pas vous laisser une
négative, c'est une festival
festif...
- c'est familial aussi..
- justement. Ce festival dépasse
la communauté LG LGBTQ.
Demain votre festival accueille
des stades un peu partout dans
le monde?
- Le festival Delas fierté à
plus de 150 événements qui
visent tous les gens. Donc
çon de faiçon de faiçon de faiçe
avancer les choses